[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois une célèbre figure
de l'art contemporain c'est aux relents
pour sa série de photographies hybride
et intitulé les femmes qui pleurent sont
en colère maria ne vit que pour son
nouveau livre guerre et père l'humoriste
davidas d'un code pour son nouveau
one-man-show animal tous les mercredis
au point virgule et le musicien et
compositeur hélios azoulay qui publie
son premier roman
moi aussi j'ai vécu mais commençons tout
de suite par notre époque qu'est ce qui
la caractérise voici les réponses en
images va commencer par la vôtre hélios
azoulay
voici alors pourquoi lui en fait c'est
le genre de question quand même qui
affole un peu l'intelligence de trouver
une image qui concentrerait toute une
époque n'est ce pas un touche-à-tout la
wec in una d'écrire et la révélera est
en fait il m'est tombé l'autre jour une
espèce d'éclaircies dans ma tête
à propos de la technologie je me suis
dit mais la technologie c'est l'homme
désamorcer alors j'ai commencé à penser
à la technologie une photo de la
technologie vie non ça marche pas c'est
trop cliché etc
je pensais à une photo très très mauvais
goût parce que je dis on vit dans une
époque très très mauvais goût et une
société d'excitation plus même que de
consommation maintenant et payer non et
puis après je suis arrivé je me suis dit
il faut proposer pas d'image à l'aller
white painting de rosenberg un grand
monochrome blanc même si non c'est pas
un peu cuit de parler de rosenberg fait
tout je pensais bah oui c'est pas
aujourd'hui c'est bien 151 et puis après
je me suis bon le monochrome le carré
noir sur fond blanc de malevitch qui
craquèle comme la banquise et
l'attaquent
je suis tombé vraiment sur ma passion
que je n'explique toujours pas et que
j'ai depuis que que que j'ai vu que j'ai
5 ans 6 enfin meubles de ma mémoire
d'enfant j'ai toujours rêvé de
téléphoner au groenland
et quand je vois ce visage aussi
accueillant recouvert petit à petit de
neige comme au temps de silence
et ça je trouve ça absolument magnifique
je me suis dit mais qu'est ce que
j'attends et je crois en plus que ça
pour être plus sérieux si le site sur le
sérieux est aussi sérieux que ça je
crois plus que ça que les inuits ont
beaucoup de choses à nous dire
sur la manière dont on devrait être
capable d'écouter leur blancheur et
alors juste moche et une bonne j'en suis
très heureux parce que généralement
parmi toutes les images qu'on me propose
chaque jour dans cette émission il ya
plutôt de la neige qui fond mais pour
une fois il ya exactement c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle
intimiste oui on va regarder votre image
davydenko tu habites aura rien et c'est
tout mignon et il y en a de moins en
moins évidemment ça rapports avec
l'actuel n'a presque aussi peu des
socialistes n'ont ni avec votre
spectacle comme on le verra dweller là
et donc ouais c'est ce passé c'est
triste de dire cet animal qui nous a
tellement fait rire va bientôt
disparaître
il nous a fait rire pourquoi d'ailleurs
tué parce que y'a ressemble à rien quoi
avec lui sinon c'est un mélange de tout
ce que l'évolution a fait tout tout
mélanger et le pire c'est que c'est
vraiment mignon plus oui c'est un gars
doux au regard dont il faut le regarder
dans les yeux
pas trop s'attarder sur le mérite a
vraiment donald voilà dans l'yonne vic
c'est presque le carré blanc de l carré
blanc met d'ailleurs ça rejoint l'image
d'hélios parce qu'en fait choisir une
image qui marque son époque c'est aussi
à partir de sa génération moi c'est la
génération des cinquantenaires donc ce
qui me frappe dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est la fluidité des
genres où l'absence de genre comment
donc ça s'était pris la photo a été
prise par mes soins c'est pour ça
qu'elle fut mauvaise whitney à new york
et c'est vrai que ça n'est pas une
oeuvre c'est vraiment les toilettes non
c'est vraiment la balade du gender donc
on mélange
en fait on est dans cette époque où moi
je suis né dans une autre époque
il ya très très longtemps et aujourd'hui
en fait on considère qu'il fait le genre
est innée et enfin le nom le sexe
matinée et le genre est acquis et
justement ait lieu si vous le savez chez
les inuit en fait vraiment les parents
selon qu'ils ont une fratrie avec
uniquement des filles ou des garçons
quand le agnm enfants nés ils
choisissent d'en faire une fille ou un
garçon indépendamment de son sexe et
donc il est élevé leurs avancées
d'ivoire
il est élevé jusqu'à ses 10 12 ans dans
le sexe que les parents ont choisi
ensuite il fait son choix et souvent ce
qu'on tonnes au choix qu'ont fait les
parents donc c'est pas quelque chose de
récent à dire moi ce qui me frappe c'est
vraiment ce monde je ne suis pas né dans
le monde dans lequel aujourd'hui ça se
produit néanmoins c'est quelque chose
d'assez strahl chez les inuits mais je
ne savais pas fou et ben voilà il ya eu
un moment quand même dans les années 90
oui il y avait un club très célèbre
amsterdam où les toilettes étaient
divisés entre hétérosexuels et
homosexuels mais il doit refaire ses
toilettes de robert filliou avec hommes
femmes artistes
c'est très bien cela alors que finissons
avec vos images à bourlens puisqu'il y
en a plusieurs
c'est un robot oui alors c'est un robot
qui me ressemble qui a les dents
artistes et robes au grand palais et ce
robot maintenant est parti à dublin
parce qu'il est en train de se
développer en intelligence artificielle
mais j'ai mélangé l'intelligence
artificielle l'intelligence sociale et
l'intelligence collective qui sont
parfois trois stupidité total mais
soyons optimistes qui a quand même
parfois certaines bien sûr c'est pas un
trucage numérique 1 il est vraiment
cette tête là oui mais on avait aussi
c'est là il ne bouge pas mais il un
générateur de mouvement est aussi un
générateur de texte donc il ya des
textes qui ce qui se propulse en fait
dans les grands écrans et lors la no id
est capable de lire l'android voilà il
est capable de lire avec ma voix parce
que j'ai enregistré 22 mille mots voilà
avec ma voix et donc après il est tout à
fait capable de lire avec le son de ma
voix voilà et maintenant il va parler en
plusieurs langues il va il va vraiment
il va se passer plein de choses et j'ai
voulu montrer cela parce
qu'effectivement je suis à nouveau dans
les robots je suis en train d'en
construire un os d'en fabriquer un autre
voilà mais qui va être pas blement
fabriqués avec des objets recyclés
le robot est ce que quand même il faut
penser à ça pour le moment tout ce qui
est du côté des nouvelles technologies
on nous montre du doigt et bien
commençons
[Musique]
orlan vous avez le corps le plus célèbre
de l'art contemporain vous en avez fait
une oeuvre d'art vous ne cessez de le
retravailler
depuis maintenant des décennies
aujourd'hui c'est un livre que vous
publié aux éditions jungle qui fait
suite à une exposition s'intitule les
femmes qui pleurent sont en colère une
série de photographies hybride et on va
les voir défiler derrière nous alors
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une photographie
hybride et et bien j'ai mélange mon
visage en fait à des oeuvres qui sont
des oeuvres référente et qui sont les
oeuvres de picasso
les portraits en fait de dora maar qu'il
a souvent vraiment pas en train de
pleurer donc il devait peut-être la
faire pleurer quand même un peu c'est la
réputation qu'a picasso oui souvent les
artistes on leur reproche d'avoir fait
pleurer leurs familles mais moi en fait
je me suis intéressé ou femmes de
l'ombre les femmes qui effectivement ont
été mus inspiratrice modèles etc et qui
ont beaucoup donné pour la notoriété de
nos grands maîtres oui ce que vous dites
mais est-ce que vous n'exagérez pas un
peu est ce que par exemple est-ce que
mona lisa beaucoup donné pour la
notoriété de léonard de vinci n'ont plus
tôt léonard de vinci qui a fait que mona
lisa aujourd'hui on se souvient en haut
il assure être à 69 c'est dans les deux
sens je pense oui mais là je pense que
là vraiment au drama il faut savoir
qu'elle était photographe
ben oui absolument pas être même et
qu'elle a complètement disparu pendant
cette époque là oui on se souvient
d'elle comme le modèle de picasso entre
1936 et 1940 donc en fait toutes les
femmes de picasso mais aussi je vais
travailler avec d'autres artistes
d'autres peintres et d'autres femmes et
j'ai celle que ces femmes qui ont été
des objets deviennent des sujets et soit
capable travers leurs larmes de se
mettre en colère très très très
sérieusement
vous pensez que quand on est en pleurs
on est toujours en colère pas toujours
non et les miennes
oui celle ci audouy je leur donne cette
colère est là roland vous dis toujours
que vos créations sont toutes politiques
et féministes en quoi celle ci le son en
quoi ces féministes là là vous vous en
rendez pas compte
simsek a beau faire quoi
j'essaye de faire sortir de l'ombre des
femmes qui étaient dans l'eau sort
véritablement de l'ombre la dora maar
est ce qu'elle soit en ressort plus
m'aider ya d'autres images ou vraiment
on la voit en train de hurler d'être en
colère deux pas du tout dans cette dans
une attaque c'est vous qu'on verra six
ehpad aura marre c'est les deux à la
fois
ah oui c'est oui parce que je
m'identifie à ces femmes de l'ombre
pourtant vous vous avez tous fait
justement depuis le début vous n'avez
jamais été ni la muse inspiratrice de
qui que ce soit d'autre que de vous je
crois et je l'espère mais justement j'ai
c'est que les autres aussi suivre mon
bel exemple maintenant c'est peut-être
plus facile que ça ne l'a été
qu'est ce qui est plus facile j'ai pas
on peut être une femme artiste
aujourd'hui sans que ça pose de problème
du temps dora maar vous croyez ça vous
n'aurez pas lues et regarder quand même
elles et les femmes qui passent dans le
grand marché
elles sont très il y en a très très peu
un peu je dis toujours donnez moi des
héros donnez-moi de zéro parce que vous
savez ce que disent les guerrilla girls
être une femme artiste c'est fantastique
parce que notre carrière peut exploser
des 80 ans ou quand on est mort alors
voyez moi j'ai fait une longue route
donc je suis très optimiste actuellement
puisque je suis près du but dans le
cadre de dora maar
vous pensez qu'elle a été aliéné par
picasso ou sublimée par picasso parce
que c'est ça l'art le mène à écouter je
dis très clairement qu'elle était aliéné
aliéné oui voilà pour vous oui jamais
subi n'est en rien non non non vous vous
le sublime et vous moi je me suis
attaqué au masque de l'ine parce que je
pense que le le masque ou que l'onda qui
soi disant faute il faut accepter on n'a
rien choisi voulait dire vers votre
visage de décence votre corps de
naissance voilà et comme de toute
manière la nature nous montre la
transformation passe contre la tête d'un
bébé la tête d'un adolescent la tête
donnait du ltte de vieillards ou du
vieillard des ou très vieille presse sa
mort les gens ne se reconnaissent même
pas et sur les photos on les reconnaît à
peine donc effectivement j'ai suivi la
nature la voie de la transformation ça
c'est clair
moi j'ai l'impression vous avez vous
êtes d'aller plus loin vous comment vous
voyez le transhumanisme d'ailleurs
puisque le transhumanisme ça ça nous
promet que l'on va nous augmente et on
va se dépasser se surpasser pas qu'on
veut c'est qu'on l'ait déjà on l'est
déjà problème isolé l'église en pratique
avant tout le monde vous voyez par
exemple moi je suis [ __ ] avec un boeuf
voiliers se voit pas mais effectivement
dans la mâchoire j'ai des hausses de
boeuf qui permettent de tenir solidement
mais un plan donc vous voyez qui est je
suis déjà très très très augmenté donc
grâce à un buzz vous n'avez jamais voulu
vous embellir vous l'avez toujours dit
vous avez eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique dans votre travail d'artiste
mais pas dans le but de vous embellir
c'était me réinventer meurent ausculté
et surtout dire que la beauté c'est une
question d'idéologie dominante un
certain moment dans un certain contexte
géographique et historique et donc ça me
paraissait extrêmement importante faire
bouger les barreaux de la cage et de
dire autre chose autrement si j'ai fait
mettre des implants qui sont amis
habituellement mis sur les i see sur les
six survient moi je les ai fait mettre
ici parce que c'était une opération qui
n'était pas censé apporter de la beauté
mais qui au contraire si on me décrit
et qu'on ne me voit pas on peut vraiment
penser que je suis un monstre absolument
indésirables si on ne voit ça ne change
pas tous les coups mais sache le changer
elles sont devenues aussi des organes de
séduction donc je suis contre les a
priori et contre les modèles qu'on nous
propose voilà donc j'ai ici on peut
dérégler approche d'ailleurs à picasso
du temps où il peignait les parents
retraite dans la mort c'est terrible
c'est horrible elle est beaucoup plus
geeks à dora maar mais en même temps
est-ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui est ce que
vous montrez c'est aussi un dommage
application sais à quel point c'est
moderne comme nous allons voir
l'hybridation de orlan et de picasso
ça fait très très 2020 mais j'ai j'adore
et j'ai toujours adoré l'oeuvre de
picasso qui est absolument fantastique
vraiment extraordinaire mais c'est vrai
que je n'aurais pas aimé vivre avec jeux
l'être humain c'est autre chose
oh mais la peinture est fantastique
quand vous dites que on a 1000 le modèle
labus l'inspiratrice on l'a un peu
oublié au détriment du grand maître
alors que il lui doit un peu de sa
notoriété
dora maar était devenu un picasso on
avait oublié qu'elle était peintre
qu'elle était est-ce que vous manque
vous avez pas devenu a piqué sol
je ne pense pas parce que j'ai quand
même tout déterminé je n'ai pas subi
picasso j'ai essayé vraiment au
contraire d'en faire quelque chose de le
décaler de le
déréglé donc je pense pas que je suis
absorbé par picasso mais c'est vrai
qu'on leur connaît ça c'est clair
qu'elle sera toi moi c'est bien
reconnaît mais je trouve ça dur je
trouve qu'on retrouve n'est que lui mais
je trouve que vous avez une manière de
voir si je peux me permettre un petit
peu les choses de manière à tout petit
peu un peu un peu binaire mais en même
temps je vois que c'est très binaire je
les vois et veut mais vraiment c'est pas
des gemmes les blonds et gmail et noir
évidemment les femmes à chaque fois
soyons féminisé pas très féminin si
c'est bon je me dis mais je connais des
hommes je veux je connais tellement
d'hommes assujettis à une mère à une
femme tu aimes tu assujettis à leur mère
ayew connaissez 147 un homme mort cette
année sanriku mais bien sûr de leur
compagne challenge parle on parle d'art
maintenant je me parle pas du tout c'est
pas du tout ça non je parle je parle je
parle vraiment d'art d'artistes et je
veux dire que ce rapport là que vous
décrivez entre l'artiste commence à
enfin à la limite torturant tous ces
modèles ou se servant d'elle pour
l'heure piétiner leur mémoire le visage
que ça je dis à moi il me semble que le
rapport entre les artistes et les femmes
est beaucoup plus complexe que ça et
j'ai en tête des écrivains et des
peintres qui sont pour le coup
complètement saoul et esclavage si je
puis dire de la nature que femme sublime
d'ailleurs absolument
voyez ce que je veux dire et je
comprends ce point de vue binaire cette
colère etc
je la comprends mais je vous avoue que
je la rencontre reprend m avec autant de
vie normal ça c'est vous seul avez vous
rencontré les bonnes personnes
les eaux ne sont pas beaux jeux
davantage une hybridation entre orlan et
picasso que dora maar ce que dora maar
n'est pas non plus un personnage majeur
de la scène artistique
si une exposition récente un livre
récent à sa position extra oui c'était
sans robben vraiment très belle
exposition aux kids ont néanmoins on
peut pas parler d'elle comme une artiste
majeure
donc je pense que il là il fait des l'a
été à mons ac a émergé et en fait donc
la femme qui pleure ce qui est vrai que
vous parlez de dora maar la femme qui
souffrait aux côtés de picasso
maintenant on oublie là l'artiste
effectivement l'homme on le sait que
quelques quelles que fussent ses
compagnes ça a été absolument terrifiant
est terrible
donc c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
par rapport à l'actualité et au
féminicide justement de montrer ces
femmes qui pleurent cette femme qui
pleure et de le dollar monte aujourd'hui
d'habiller d'un mot en fait j'étais avec
une amie à quelques jours elle elle
organise un festival de musique dédiée
aux femmes en fait dans la musique
classique qui pour le coup elle il n'ya
même pas leur image qui reste il reste
rien du tout et la soeur de moteur ne va
notamment ou audio vous d'autres vous
vraiment je ne connaissais absolument
pas les noms et elle me disait voilà si
je te dis mozart vivaldi schubert tout
de suite à des non surement un nom de
compositrice effectivement je dis non je
ne sais pas je sais qu'en retenez vol
mais bon c'est ses deux plus récents
donc voilà ça va pas et elles ont tous
les domaines et c'est dans tous les
domaines c'est vrai mais mais c'est vrai
que c'est quand on fait remarquer même
si on le sait intuitivement c'est quand
on donne des exemples comme ça on s'en
rend compte à quel point il ya une part
de là deux histoires qui va être
complètement disparu quoi le
l'innovation est visible jusqu'à
vendredi donc jusqu'à 7 à la sorbonne
opinion à la galerie de la sorbonne we
ll sous sa nouvelle galerie voilà et
sinon le livre qui vient de paraître aux
éditions juge anac la même il faut
honorer les éditeurs
[Musique]
marianne vie que vous publiez guéri père
aux éditions fayard c'est un roman mais
très autobiographique
je veux dire que m'avait réconcilier
avec un genre littéraire c'est ce qui
est très présent en france 1 quand on
fait des romans sur son père sa mère son
frère sa soeur
j'en peux plus ça me casse les bonbons
et vous j'adore parce que c'est bien
écrit l'ubs est ce que vous racontez
vraiment des choses alors il faut sauf
dans le précédent qui s'intitulait rien
de ce qui est humain des tontes e7 est
paru l'année dernière vous racontiez
vous êtes la nièce du saint-laurent il
vous racontiez qu'il y avait un secret
dans cette famille dans la famille dans
votre famille maternelle péchalat vous
êtes la fille de la soeur d'yves saint
laurent et il y avait un secret de
famille qui dont vous êtes persuadé la
grand mère a été violée
la mère a été violée enfin la mère louis
st-laurent pardonnez-moi a elle même été
violée alors qu'elle était elle même la
fille d'un viol et vous pensez que bien
que les enfants ne les gb su vous êtes
la première à l'avoir appris ça s'est
transmis dans la consume dans la
démission la voilà alors là vous vous
êtes attaqués à votre père dont chacun
son tour voilà et or il ya là la morale
dans votre livre vous dites que dès
qu'on veut éclaircir des mystères on
prend des risques donc vous avez pris
des risques avec votre père qui était
quelqu'un que vous connaissez assez peu
et qui est mort il y à peu il vous a
élevé jusqu'à l'âge de 7 ans a été le
père idéal un type très beau souvent
quand on a la chance d'avoir eu un père
présent dans son enfance
on en fait un héros chili au garçon
ensuite à se compliquer par y aura très
beau riche il avait un avion où nous
emmener dans son avion il vous élevez
puisque s'était séparé votre toit mer et
puis à 7 ans il vous a rendu à assab à
votre mère et puis il a disparu et après
sa mort vous avez vous eu là aussi aller
voir un peu ce qui se cachait derrière
tout ça et c'est terrible elle dit c est
ce que véritablement à chaque fois
est-ce que vous pensez que pour chacun
ce serait comme ça si chacun d'entre
nous allait enquêter sur son père sa
mère je ne sais qui elle est on
trouverait des choses aussi énorme
frédéric on est on appartient à une
génération qui a traversé le dont les
parents les grands-parents ont traversé
le xxème siècle forcément chaque famille
je pense enfin on en a quelques-unes
a subi ce siècle ce qu'alain siècle le
terrible donc il en reste quelque chose
alors soit ça appartient un secret de
famille soit c'est partager et voilà
donc balle en l'occurrence était une ce
ne sont que des secrets de famille
première découverte vous découvrez que
votre père était membre de l'oas et la
guerre d'algérie vous dire que dans sa
famille comme dans la famille saint
laurent il habitait l'algérie française
c'était ce qu'on appelait des colons lui
c'était une famille très riche il
rejoint l'ol à la fin de la guerre
d'algérie vous apprenez par la même
occasion que votre mère elle même qui
était très jeune était elle aussi membre
de l'oas ils sont alors en lui non pas
du tout alors justement comme vous le
savez vous avez lu les deux livres le
précédent
j'étais très proche de mon oncle donc
j'étais plutôt élevée dans un roger de
de tout ce monde de l'algérie française
des pieds noirs de la voilà donc j'ai eu
les fat est élevé plus tôt dans cet
esprit là et alors quelles découvertes
vous apparaissez finalement il a été
membre de noël ce mais très actif tout à
coup vous découvrez que vous avez un
père qui a été un terroriste et un
assassin et qui a été condamné à mort
par contumace
il ya même quelqu'un qu'on connaît qui
s'appelle michel darrois qui à un moment
vous apprend que c'est lui qui a obtenu
son ami steam est oui alors un hasard si
c'est un hasard si ça existe mais c'est
vrai qu'au cours de mon adolescence en
fait avec l'homme qui allait devenir au
mari elle était amie avec
françois son fils et donc on allait
passer des week-ends chez eux ils
étaient là et c'est vrai qu'il a été
interpellé par par ce nom de famille ce
patronyme vic et je comprenais pas très
bien pourquoi et cette famille a subi un
drame et il a perdu sa fille et donc au
moment des obsèques il me dit j'ai sauvé
la vie de votre père là c'était vraiment
quelque chose de mystérieux déjà mon
père était devenu un homme mystérieux un
inconnu alors là vous ne saviez
quasiment plus qu'il était valable et
j'ai ça et j'ai cette information et
qu'est ce que je vais en faire et je
n'avais pas envie d'en faire un grand
chose voilà je sentais pas levé oblitéré
valait pas grand fasse quelque chose sur
le moment j'étais pas prête
oui sans aucun doute donc condamné à
mort par contumace
amnistié grâce à michel baroin grâce à
michel baroin il s'était enfui avec
votre mère on a viré ont fui en espagne
où se retrouver à peu près tous les
exilés vers le mondial après les guerres
coloniales
ça c'est la première découverte la
deuxième découverte découvrez que votre
grand mère que vous pensiez alsacienne
en fait étaient allemands mais oui et
donc c'était un homme elle avait alors
tiré un fil il ya quelque chose d'énorme
s'il veut la figure alors là c'est trop
grave
bon il se trouve qu'elle a épousé veut
tous sont votre grand père après la
première guerre mondiale
plutôt que de dire qu'elle était
allemande alors qu'on détestait les
[ __ ] comme on les appelait doit mieux
passé pour alsacienne voilà on l'a fait
passer pour alsacienne d'où cet exil
très luxueux en algérie française voilà
mais alors il se trouve que avec la
grand mère il ya aussi le frère de la
grand-mère ya le frère de la grand-mère
alors il est tellement il est en
allemagne donc forcément facile de la
wehrmacht et vous apercevez que le
personnage montrent ils pas responsables
de ces ailleurs le personnage vous
m'envoyez inventé par votre père qui
quand vous étiez en forme vous raconter
des histoires du capitaine franck tu es
en fait le capitaine france c'était
votre nom votre grand ton oui c'est ya
des télécoms de votre père ont fait pas
des cités ceux des ancêtres police je
vous rejoins sens personnellement après
le culte
contraire d'ailleurs des horizons
meilleurs dit désolé lui c'est quoi
c'est pas utile et vous n'y croyez
connaître pour s'en défaire parce que si
vous les ignorez vous les subissent et
donc voila quand votre pays que j'ignore
on les subit
oui on parlera gfa et met lui en
l'occurrence et il a perdu sa femme ses
enfants par l'as guerre et ils sont
morts dans les bombardements de l'alma
lillers pas enfin c'est pas d' assassin
oui on peut prédire qu'il est à même
chance angle est donc allé sur le front
de l'est
et d'ailleurs il réalise à cette
occasion parce que le front de l'est
c'est vraiment quelque chose cette scène
on l'oubli ont le culte j'ai
l'impression que les gens se rendent pas
compte
en ce moment il ya un film qui s'appelle
1917 sur la boucherie de verna mais j'ai
l'impression que ce front de l'est avec
ses millions et ses millions de morts
guerre mondiale on l'oubli parce que
voilà il subissait de raconter à votre
votre père c'était la barbarie total
dont il ya donc sept cette lettre cette
lettre rédigée en allemand
parce que du coup je découvre que la
langue maternelle de mon père c'est
l'allemand a oui forcément
donc j'ai jamais parler allemand devant
moi je ne suis pas une part les
allemands qu'avec sa mère of elle a donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
étonnant
et il ya cette guerre où on voit tout le
mea culpa de cet homme sur sur la guerre
sur les horreurs de la guerre qui prend
pas parti pour maintenant pour un autre
et donc le franc selon l'officiel avait
un art et qui décident décide de
finalement enfin de renoncer à tout ça
de baisser les armes
mais enfin il pour renoncer à tout ça il
s'engage dans la légion étrangère parce
qu'il est fait prisonnier il est donc il
a une famille il est ruiné toute façon
en allemagne sa maison n'existe plus
donc autant s'engager dans la légion et
la légion étrangère il faut savoir il ya
là deux chines ulaval ça va que la
légion à recruter dans les prisons
françaises
tous les officiers allemands à tous les
soldats allemands et donc en fait on
oublie que l'indochine c'était aussi une
guerre avec beaucoup d'allemands oui
peut-être plus que plus d'un an que deux
français et une petite bière rousse pour
digérer toutes ces informations épauler
ses magnifiques chansons si on se
retrouve dans un instant
[Musique]
arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtise la france a intérêt
à maintenir de français parce que selon
le crr instruments qu'ils ont de
protection de ses intérêts économiques
en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qui était
fait entre pays africains et sur lequel
la france et l'europe avait pas grand
chose à dire en question au ladakh fixe
avec nos hommes et c'est est-ce que
c'est pipe mot n'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui en afrique c'est pas d'avoir
une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de kira entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
[Musique]
je serai votre sentiment sur les
mouvements concernant la manifestation
contre la retraite quand il ya autant de
travail qui a autant de chômeurs autant
de gens qui sont dans la logique comme
on dit aujourd'hui du burn out
qu'est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas à
repenser le travail c'est vraiment une
question philosophique pour moi je
défends les gilet jaune qui sont pour
moi les les sous prolétaires je défends
également ces gens là qui pour le coup
ce sont les prolétaires mais qui sont
organisés pour parce que c'est toujours
les mêmes qui payent les pots plus
modestes et c est pourquoi ce sont
toujours les mêmes qui échappent soit à
l'impôt soit aux ponctions d'autres
choses qui font que s'il y avait
vraiment un désir d'équité
les français seraient produits et même
en plus à même de devenir qu'il consente
à ce traitement est ce que vous avez
compris quelle était la revendication
haut niveau au moment des gilets jaunes
tout au départ ce sont juste des gens
qui disent si vous augmentez le prix du
carburant nous on va pas pouvoir des
gens disaient mais moi je suis chez mes
parents parce que je ne peux pas me
payer un loyer alors que je travaille
donc dès le départ c'était une
revendication de dignité mais vous avez
dit on n'a pas écouté ces gens là
comment vouliez vous les écoutez puisque
personne ne prenait la parole et
personne n'était légitime pour
l'apprendre y en un qui est légitime
pour prendre la parole sur ce sujet là
ça s'appelle un président de la
république parce qu'il est investi de la
souveraineté nationale
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui hors long
pour les femmes qui pleurent sont encore
l'air elle en a profité elle a profité
de la pause pour changer de veste
l'humoriste david est un code pour son
nouveau spectacle animal tous les
mercredis au point virgule hélios
azoulay pour son premier roman
moi aussi j'ai vécu et marianne vit que
pour guéret père on continue de parler
de ce roman autobiographique ou plutôt
au fond vous êtes assez peu présente
dans ce livre c'est plutôt je m'efface
devant les personnages ses fantômes
tourne autour de vous pour en finir avec
l'oncle france où le capitaine france
comme l'appelait votre père homme dont
vous n'aviez jamais entendu parler a bel
et bien à caen il va donc se retrouver
avec la légion étrangère dien bien phu
il revient de genk où surviennent aucune
chance et il se réengagent au 1er rep le
1er régiment étranger parachutiste pour
l'algérie c'est donc rien faire d'autre
en fait voilà ces hommes l'engrenage il
faut imaginer l'engrenage de ces hommes
qui ont fait ces trois guerres
successivement que c'est pas le seul
il ya aussi des français au fait ces
trois gars de chez lui il ne nourrit
aucune illusion il sait que ce sont des
guerres perdues d'avant s'il en a une
certaine habitude il a perdu la seconde
guerre mondiale la première déjà il a
jamais laissé deux frères sans ouais il
avait perdu la deuxième guerre mondiale
il a perdu l'indochine
il sait qu'on va perdre l'algérie le cio
lui ne fait aucun doute
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
des guerriers antique sur la couverture
ou est ce que c'est vraiment une
référence à omer à l'illiade et
l'odyssée et à l'illiade et c'est vrai
que c'est ces conflits c'est vraiment la
démesure des hommes et ensuite qu'est ce
qui se passe après mais ces
interminables surtout il n'ya pas
d'après à lui évalué le malheureux l'un
pas d'après mais qu'est ce qui se passe
en fait qu'est-ce qu'on en fait nous une
fois que les combats ont cessé
qu'est-ce qu'on fait tout ça c'est
l'histoire de l'odyssée ensuite est en
moi j'ai fait une oeuvre qui s'appelle
l'origine de la guerre et c'est un homme
oui nul mais bien sûr j'ai ramené le
magnifique m
à l'origine je connais votre formidable
l effet ces derniers vont mal et donc
lui il va mourir d'ailleurs à la fin de
l'indépendance de au monde la débal'art
aussi lâché 22 alors qu'il n'était pas
du tout contre l'algérie mais enfin il
va payer pour les autres et puis encore
une découverte
il y en a encore un c'est le demi-frère
du de votre père oui mais voilà esaü de
compliquer quand même mais d'un premier
mariage de votre grand-père demi-frère
qui s'appelait richard qui avait été
beaucoup plus âgée que votre père est et
qui lui s'engage dans la waffen ss les
22 16 france fait la division chalamov
division charlemagne
en fait c'était très difficile
d'absorber tout ça comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer c'est pas vraiment les
valeurs et donc c'est ce que j'explique
comment on sera prêts à peu près
approprient une une saga familiale
envers laquelle on est complètement
dressées finalement rue parce que au
fond quand on est si vous l'aviez su
toujours vous auriez peut-être passé
votre vie a justifié vous en scène alors
que là aujourd'hui vous héritez
d'ancêtres qui a priori donc il faut
bien faire quelque chose il faut pas
qu'il reste au statut d'ennemi donc on
en fait des personnages de romans c'est
une façon de s'en dessaisir parce que
quand on écrit finalement on dépose
quelque chose quelque part et ça ne vous
appartient plus parce que là ça
appartient à tous les lecteurs et ses
devient un objet en fait tu en avais de
5 plus le sujet je suis assez gentille
mais je rappelle que dans votre livre
précédent vous le disiez que des
traumatismes comme les viols par exemple
pour vous été transmis quand bien même
on ignorait ce qu'était le cas de votre
mère et d'yves saint laurent ils ne
savaient pas que leur ce qui était
arrivé à leur mère et à leur grand mère
et pourtant vous êtes persuadé que c'est
ce qu'ils les avaient rendus l'un et
l'autre auto destructeur que donc ce
traumatisme au fond se transmettait
collera dans l'inconscient familial mais
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu
une femme qui s'appelle anne ancelin
schützenberger qui a beaucoup travaillé
sur la psychogénéalogie cetera les la
transmission des traumatismes familiaux
et en fait récemment
ça a été prouvé un point de vue
génétique les chercheurs d'éminents
chercheurs et ça fait moins d'une
dizaine d'années on s'aperçoit ils n'ont
pas fait encore des tests sur des
humains mais des homos sur des souris
ils se sont aperçus que c'est ces jeunes
d'expressif se transmettait sur trois
générations
alors comme des salles donc voilà donc
là je sors je sors de la
psychogénéalogie cnra et pourrait même
faire son nom mais qu'en est il alors du
mas anglais mais chose quel est votre
diagnostic marianne vie qu'en ce qui
concerne ce qui conduit au ski et je
suivrai plumeau pour ce qui concerne on
veut dire le votre héritage génétique
alors entre guillemets du côté de votre
père est ce que lui on voit bien lui
savait tout ça mais au fond il n'a cessé
il n'en parlait pas ils n'ont pas les
pas il a voulu faire sa guerre ça a été
le s il est devenu à son tour un tueur
d'ailleurs oui
ensuite il s'est ruiné il est parti en
là au moment vous ne le voyez plus il
est en argentine il est en afrique noire
il est au brésil
j'ai l'impression de son héritage à lui
c'est le racisme c'est la défaite est là
alors c'est la violence
celui cherche absolument aucune excuse
vous avez le livre vous savez néanmoins
il faut voir ce qu'était la france
les familles françaises depuis même bien
avant la sphère dreyfus enfin mettons
remontant puisque le livre montrent la
moitié du 19e siècle les familles francs
les bourgeois français c'était
l'antisémitisme était sous jacent enfin
mieux que sous jacent d'ailleurs assez
dense et un parti pas dans l affaire
dreyfus montre qu'il ya autant de rayons
x émis
we had an elle a envoyé enfin pour des
raisons différentes mais en fait c'était
c'était quelque chose cette france très
catholique
c'est un vendeur matage oui on voit la
star mais ensuite il ya effectivement
des certains qui sont allé un peu plus
loin que d'autres mais c'est un
formatage et c'est vrai que c'est
d'ailleurs sa salle montre le film de
polanski l'a pas mal montrer puisque le
héros du film finalement picarel human
antisémites et donc sonné t on est donc
voilà exactement on était quand même on
est des dreyfusards pas par conviction
oui moi je ne cherche pas non plus à
accuser votre lait c'est une famille
voilà c'est une famille antisémistes
racisme c'est le drame voilà et donc
quand j'ai découvert c'est très dur
parce que vous imaginez moi j'ai grandi
à l'ombre de deux d'yves saint laurent
et pierre bergé qui était quand même
plutôt à gauche extrêmement qu'il ne
supportait pas ni le racisme et
l'antisémitisme et donc je me retrouve
avec un héritage khoury quoi voilà ouais
donc l histoire se décident de faire une
seule chose que je sache faire j'en fais
un livre voilà donc ça ne m'appartient
plus néanmoins l'histoire et suel est
racontée pour ne pas que ça se
transmettent après ses enfants voilà
parce que c'est vraiment le l'essentiel
pour moi
le livre s'intitule galères lpr et il
vient de sortir chez fayard
[Musique]
david alain cotte vous jouez votre
nouveau spectacle animal au point
virgule
vous dites que les humoristes femme
aujourd'hui peuvent aller beaucoup plus
loin que les autres mais c'est la rançon
de quelques avait subi dans le sujet
dont nous parlait aux relents tout à
l'heure mais ça je ne fais tivement je
les jouais quand je les jouais à
l'européen à la base c'était une
représentation exceptionnelle
j'avais fait pour la journée mondiale
des droits des animaux ça doit rester
exceptionnelle et puis finalement bas je
rejoue au point virgule et dans la
version donc longue que j'ai fait à
l'européen je faisais des blagues un peu
sur d'autres sujets et notamment
j'évacue les sujets dont j'allais pas
parler notamment le féminisme tout ce
qui passe en ce moment et c'est vrai que
les humoristes femmes peuvent dire des
choses beaucoup plus trash sur scène
notamment liée au sexe et je dis voilà
une fille peut arriver sur scène et vous
dire hier soir c'était le planétarium
dans ma chatte je voyais tellement des
toiles mon mec m'a tellement déglingué
là tu vas vous allez dire c'est aux
essais féministe et si en plus elle
s'est il passé jeanne d'arc alors que si
moi j'arrive en disant rien soir ma
copine a mis à god ceinture elle a pris
mon anus pour un bilboquet dira elle a
maigri bigard c'est moi que je le
maintiens fabrice et pas que dans
l'humour on voit un certain nombre de
féministes militantes ça les plateaux
télévisés au dire des trucs sur les
sommes qu'on devrait qualifiée de
sexiste et on ne fait pas oui il ya un
balancier quoi c'est une période
j'imagine mais baissé en tout cas on en
humour c'est assez c'est assez frappant
parce que c'est vrai que c'est des trucs
en général assez assez trash
ouais c'est assez sexuelle qui passe et
tout le monde faire assez génial c'est
bien la parole se libère
évidemment si moi je racontais mes
affaires sexuelles on dira alors si on
n'arrive à rien en même temps si je peux
me permet il ya un truc marrant parce
que et je suis d'accord mais très
souvent on entend on peut pas dire et on
finit toujours par dire 5
en fait on fait on peut dire
je connais pas oublié le nom de cette
figure de style mais c'est exactement ce
que je fais alors vos spécialités c'est
d'aborder des sujets introspectif mais
grave
là vous comptez nous faire rire avec
l'extinction des espèces avec la mort
programmée de milliards d'animaux chaque
année tout ça pour nous nourrir
avec le réchauffement climatique avec
greta tune bergues
enfin plutôt avec les admonestations
d'un art et est une tout en étant
vous-même écolo anxieux comme vous le
bruit bah oui oui comme tout dernier on
me dit si on est que matt aux sceptiques
c'est plus marrant c'est plus facile de
rigoler de tout ça que quand on est
ouais quand on est klimato anxieux ouais
c'est sûr avec quand on est klimato
anxieux en fait je pense qu'on est on
est c'est comme les flexitariens enfin
moi je fais déjà dit je me suis fait que
si t'as rien à dire c'est à dire que en
gros je fais rien comment j'arrivais au
moins voilà on aime on n'arrive pas à
changer nos habitudes je vais tout inter
gens parlent beaucoup parce que j'ai lu
le bouquin qui s'appelle le bug humain
sur le fonctionnement du cerveau et sur
le fait que notre fonctionnement
cérébral nous empêche de prendre des
décisions radicales la plupart du temps
et donc c'est ça on est on est tous ces
coups anxieux mais en fait on change
rien et alors par exemple et vous
raconter ce qui arrive aux vaches à qui
on greffe à hublot je proposerai qu'on
regarde cours exprès je pensais encore
pire pour une vache laitière
c'est devenir une vache avec blue que
ces matches où tu prends une vache
normal tu vas tu vas tu découpes un trou
dans son ventre
environ un centimètre de diamètre un
temps relève le morceau est une erreur
et blue tooth anesthésie locale un bien
sûr on n'est pas des monstres le plot en
plastique là il s'ouvre et tu peux
mettre directement des choses dans
l'estomac de la vache
1 tu veux mettre des mélanges d'herbes
pour voir comment elle digère pas ce que
les vaches chairman faut le savoir
on fait ça parce que les vaches petro
comédie genre elle est trop
voilà ils ont fait deux réunions
j'imagine tu vois on a qu'à voir les
gars qu'est ce qu'on fait peut-être trop
et bien des cas fin du mois on pourrait
faire un trop dedans et les autres vont
pas dit michel arrête la kétamine
comment vit on y met carrément mais
c'est une bonne idée ça mais ouais
attend mais vas-y tu développes
développe un moment je t'écoute tu sais
bien quand je vois des poussant ça me
déstresse
quand vous re des spectacles comme celui
là bas public devant un oui je fais
beaucoup de plateau il ya un an de
plateau à paris non des comedy club donc
je rôde par petits bouts et puis quand
même avant que comme ça d'être une
représentation unique encore une fois
j'ai quand même fait quelques fils
agents publics dans un petit théâtre et
dans ces cas-là on sait que ça peut
aider un rire assez grinçant
ah oui oui si vous racontez sur les
animaux a priori tout le monde aime les
animaux vous le faisiez d'ailleurs dans
votre spectacle mangue et aujourd'
applaudir ceux qui aiment les animaux
qui ont la peau 17 désirez vous
demandiez qui mange des animaux ils
m'ont tabassé mais c'est notre notre
biais permanent d'être à l'avant
vacances voilà la mauvaise conscience
d'être concernés mais en même temps rien
changé et c'est vrai que le coût des
bâches à luz et il ya beaucoup de trucs
que j'apprends au genre les vaches elles
beau je sais que ça a été pas mal
montrer on a des photos m'avaient les
photos il ya d'autres trucs que
j'apprends aux gens vraiment je vois les
gens qui ont les yeux comme ça en disant
c'est impossible si bas si on le fait
aussi
alors il est tout et que vous apprenez
pas c'est qu'il ya une jeune fille
s'appelle grit est une règle à tout le
monde la connaît et qu'elle est quand
même un peu vilipendé on vous écoute
greta sauce verte me vois bien sûr il
est temps suédoise écolo 16 ans un peu
flippante avec des tresses
jean annabelle en v gagnent tout et
quand elle était venue en france
l'assemblée nationale faire un disque où
il ya plein de députés aient l'air om
qui ont refusé de l'entendre
ils ont fait un nom c'est de l'écouter
on veut pas être manipulé manipuler
c'est notre boulot dodo
[Musique]
ça râle un ciment sacs elle est
manipulée greta thunder mais mani pulite
marquis dire naturalia biocoop ladite
l'herbe
il ya quelqu'un derrière elle ben
shepherd ils sont à jeu roman polanski
est une tendance de votre nouveau
spectacle david ces mêmes dropping way
hoping for ski mais en même temps on est
obligés de c'est toujours un peu les
mêmes têtes de turc
on ébauche à prendre n'importe qui n'ont
pas je vais prendre match 9 maintenant
mais voilà vient d'arriver sur le marché
à nouveau à fond mais bon il va pas
rester longtemps je pense mais non mais
on est obligé on est obligé si on veut
faire passer des difficultés le truc si
on veut faire passer des entre
guillemets des messages en tout cas des
informations on est obligé après d'avoir
des référents hyper immédiat je connais
revoilà claire où tout est d'accord on
ne comprend la bad et le fait est que
tout le monde comprend la vanne
autre exemple d'ailleurs mes fesses et
quand vous parlez de ses news alors le
réchauffement de la planète je pense que
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
il est là 1
on n'est pas sur ces news en débattre
je connais les débats de ces news avec
pascal praud pascal praud l'autre fois
parce qu'elle prouve l'a dit un truc qui
la nient pas durant au moins 3 degrés
dans les yvelines
alors le réchauffement de la planète
c'est du niveau logique de j'ai vu un
juif dans le val de marne alors la chaux
[Musique]
ils sont là des batteries connaissent
rien en sciences et s'ils connaissent
autant que tariq ramadan après les
mineurs autres name dropping tariq
ramadan tariq ramadan pascal praud bah
oui j'aime pas c'est bien je pense que
c'est pas mal aussi de enfin ça ne se
passe pas un peu long terme enfin si
c'est volontaire mais je pourrais faire
tout un sketch où je me fiche de la
gueule de pascal praud et des débats sur
ces news ou sur bfm je pourrais faire
tout un sketch ludique tariq ramadan est
un connard mais je trouve c'est plus
marrant de parler d'autre chose et de
faire une référence comme ça par en
dessous comme comme quand j'étais coupé
voilà on a pu te disais je parlais du
ghb la drogue du ghb la drogue du viol
visait ghb tout le monde voit c'est
l'équivalent drogue du quinquennat
françois hollande dire tu te rappelles
tu te rappelles rien met un peu mal au
cul voilà je vous c'est plus marrant de
parler françois hollande comme ça et de
faire tout en se fichant là où vous
innovez j'ai l'impression c'est on vous
êtes à qu'on marque rénovée par rapport
à vos précédents spectacles et puis
parce que ça se fait pas beaucoup
d'appels de s'en prendre aux maths parce
que les marques elles sont puissantes et
répondent elles peuvent ils assurent la
exemple on va en voir
vous prenez un risque la halle à mon
avis vous prenez un risque et je me
désolidarise pourra vous avez regardé je
supporte pas qu'on ait marqué c'est
d'avoir l'air gentille les mares sont là
pour faire de l'argent
faut arrêter un michel et augusto
ils seront avec leurs affiches dans le
métro là on avait très peur des loups
d'honneur avec leurs tee gribouillis
leur photo collée dessus on fait des
bons gâteaux avec comme jordi
collaborateurs na na waie nyatto le
secret c'est l'amour qu'on met dedans
aaa
[Musique]
tu sais quoi moi je pense qu'ils se
branle alors cookies michel augustin tu
tiens même mieux je pense qu'ils pèsent
des gens dans leur classe michel et
augustin tu vois ça en mode pulp fiction
bah c'est du genre est maintenant michel
mateu sataniser pendant quelques mois un
justin je vais te mettre des pépites de
chocolat on est les premiers on est trop
voilà 50 millions de chiffre d'affaires
par an alors ça m'étonnerait que le
bilan comptable et le coloris on faisait
attention à pas dépassées on voit bien
que c'est beaucoup plus risqué parce
qu'à la différence de poids lorsque
woods ramadan il peut vraiment vous
attaquer et gagneront qu'au droit à
l'humour a quand même je pense qu'ils
perdraient j'ai fait des droits avant
quand même oui mais le droit et de la
pub donc nancy mais justement il ya
diffamation
voilà je pense qu'il serait pas
suffisamment bête pour m'attaquer mais
on ne s'entend mieux j'aimerais beaucoup
aller au fond la morale de tout ça c'est
ça va dans le sens de ce que disait
hélios tout à l'heure les humoristes
ipad dire l'on peut plus rien dire tout
le temps vous vous dites jamais attaqué
bien sûr qu'à la regarder tout ce que
vous vous permettez parce que vous êtes
chez vous à être attaqué par jean paul
tartempion chez lui qui m'envoie un
message sur twitter
oui voilà mais dans deux mois comme à
l'aller après après je pense que si je
si je sortais vraiment des infos comédie
lui c'est là je serai attaqué mais comme
c'est juste des blagues c'est pas grave
voilà les gens les gens passent à autre
chose mais je trouve ça bien ceci dit
d'attaqué sur l'infantilisation toutes
ces marques qui essaient de nous
remettre dans une ambiance d'enfance en
nous disant ce n'est pas grave c'est que
des bons produits ça te rappelleras ta
grand-mère ya rien de pire en fait pour
continuer à détruire la planète surtout
s'ils se rappellent la grand-mère de
marianne mais surtout si le sucre croyez
moi c'est être précieux le spectacle de
david asselin coach institut l'animal et
c'est au point virgule tout petit but
l'historique tous les mercredis à 19h
[Musique]
hélios azoulay vous êtes compositeur
vous êtes musicien je les dis mais là
c'est pour votre premier roman que je
vous invite et moi aussi j'ai vécu qui
vient de paraître chez flammarion c'est
presque la conclusion de tout ce qu'on a
raconté aussi j'ai vécu me écrivait j'ai
été un enfant heureux dans une enfance
malheureuse qu'entendez-vous par là bas
vous savez je crois que ce qui est
entendu par là se voit sur la couverture
puisque c'est une photo qui a été prise
de moi enfant
ouais enfants quand j'avais peut-être je
sais pas cette envie temps je ne sais
pas du tout et je questionne en fait ce
sourire parce que quand je vois le
désastre de cette enfance et que je vois
l'éclat de ce sourire de ses dents
tordues génial mentor bull mais je me
dis mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bonheur et je le trouve tellement enfin
pardonnez moi je parle pas de moi je dis
pas je me trouve sublime mais je trouve
que cette capacité d'avoir été
effectivement heureux dans une enfance
malheureuse d'un mois s'est pas
maintenue à portée de de deux de ses
dents je sais pas un horizon possible je
trouve que c'est quand même assez
miraculeux et c'est ça que je constate
et j'ai constaté en écrivant ce livre
est par exemple alors ça revient à ce
que racontait mariannick sauf que vous
vous l'avez vécu pas elle elle s'en est
aperçu bien après qu'est ce que fait on
va pas entrer dans les péripéties de ce
qu'il fallait très particulier il faut
le dire mais qu'est ce que ça fait
d'être dans une famille qui vit dans
l'illégalité par exemple mais ça vous
condamne au silence autrement dit quand
vous avez un beau père une mère etc qui
sont dans une vie de trafic bien fait
vous pouvez pas parler dire que vous
inventez et d'ailleurs c'est hallucinant
comme les gens croient à ce que vous
racontez oui son agent immobilier son
machin ils sont alors voyez mais c'est
dingue et donc vous passez votre vie a
finalement à ne pas pouvoir parler et se
livre sans être une banale psychanalyse
bien mais c'est très libérateur et de
libératoire du rabbin voilà c'était ce à
quoi
voilà et ce poids naturellement du
silence que là pour le coup j'étais bien
obligé de porter parce que si vous dites
la vérité
votre beau père ou de mère tout le monde
va en prison enfin voyons clairement
badens vous vous taisez bon voilà
peut-être complice mai
c'est pas grave c'était une époque le
mène maintenant je vous avoue que je me
suis très très heureux d'avoir libéré
tout ça la littérature c'est un grand un
mouvement de libération mais de soi même
oui je rêve d autant mais c'est vrai
cette histoire de fantômes dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure elle et elle et
elle
allez vous vous dites lebon fantôme tout
le temps mais complètement ses terres
jeu je crois vraiment que nous sommes
peuple est en fait je crois qu'à
l'intérieur de nous il ya des gens qui
tapent vient peut-être même des gens qui
hurlent et que la libérale à la
libération par le roman c'est d'abord
les libérer et donc les faire parler en
tant que musicien j'aurais pu composer
des oeuvres j'en ai composé bon ou g2
libérer des choses mais quand même le
roman c'est la possibilité de mettre des
mots dans la bouche des gens alors c'est
pas une autobiographie au sens strict du
terme
la vie est si je puis dire réinventer
dédommager éternellement rapiécé par le
rire l'humour
l'extravagance l'incroyable que le
crédible et de ce point de vue là c'est
votre la forme romanesque avec forme
avec laquelle j'avais un petit peu de
défiance truc quand même le roman et non
c'est bon il est arrivé sous des écrits
sous une forme un peu spéciale on y
reviendra mais d'abord j'ai une
impression
pour avoir lu marianne vite et vous
autres vous croyez qu'on était entouré
de fantômes et que depuis le début des
années 2000 maintenant on serait habitée
par les fantômes hisserait à l'intérieur
de nous et pas autour de nous 20 c'est
un peu ce que vous pensez aussi marianne
way it is not it france mais oui mais il
ya possibilité c'est à dire soit on ya
possibilité de s'en séparer
oui ça dépend en fait cher feneri ce
qu'on appelle fantôme
oui ça dépend ce qu'on appelle fantôme
parce que si on appelle fantôme
l'image qu'on a du fantôme dans un
château écossais qui fait ou bon là
effectivement celui là il est extérieur
mais si on pense ce que moi je pense
sans barbouillé sade mysticisme ou de
croyance stupide mais que effectivement
je sais pas il ya quand même des gens
qui parlent donc des gens qui graves des
choses en nous à l'intérieur la vie
quand on dit quand quelqu'un une parole
qui blessent
c'est une parole qui s'inscrit met dans
la peau même donc jusqu'à l'intérieur de
la peau donc il arrive à un moment où ça
doit sortir voilà et il me semble que
l'art c'est le privilège de l'art de la
littérature et donc du roman de se
réarmer
un bonheur cas là il faut dire que la
forme est très particulière il ya
beaucoup de blanc il ya des silences
dans votre roman la ponctuation est
spécial ça peut sembler assez désordonné
en apparence chaotique même c'est pas
vraiment complète c'est parce que
j'appelle le désert le cas où c'est
l'état du monde
ouais le descendre c'est mettre le
désordre c'est le bordel dans le cas où
si vous voulez toujours est il que c'est
une forme un peu singulière et or
l'enfant c'est un territoire qui semble
privilégier pour écrire un roman
notamment premier roman absolue est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas compliquer la tâche
non pas du tout parce que je dois vous
avouer que ce que vous appelez
extravagances dans la forme
ma part et moi comme vraiment d'un
naturel absolue et c'était pas une offre
ni j'avais longtemps je vous connais
finalement c'est plus proche de vous
gaver que je suis obligé de prendre
comme un compliment mais effectivement
il n'y a pas de point c'est à dire qu à
la place de points il ya des blancs il
ya des espaces
tout simplement parce qu'il me semble
que c'est peut-être une volonté
rythmique donc deux compositeurs ce
blanc ses respirations
mais il semble aussi qu'il y a si vous
voulez même dans la forme du roman entre
toutes les phrases il ya quand même le
mensonge de tout raconter
et il me semble que ce blanc qui
pourraient être des 50 rythmiques sont
plus que des syncopes dans un autre des
évanouissements
et c'est comme si à chaque fois la
mémoire s'évanouissent est quelque peu
et ressurgissent et 2,3 cm après et puis
je vous avoue il ya aussi autre chose
c'est que j'aurais pu faire et des tas
de romancier l'ont fait et le premier
c'est erik satie dans ses conférences
qui mettait des petits points des petits
points des petits points des petits
points des petits points j'aurais pu
faire les trois petits points mais ça
m'apparaissait voilà je respirais pas
assez d'ailleurs ça rejoint tout à fait
la blancheur inuits que je vous montrais
monde alors je crois que je n'ai été
dans cette blancheur yahia le rythme il
ya le souffle à la respiration et du
coup ça donne
il me semble et ce que j'en sais des
lecteurs quelque chose de tout à fait
fluide
deux traits parler et justement ça
prépare au fond le fait que vous allez
l'interpréter au théâtre à partir de
samedi prochain
oui la contrescarpe tous les samedis 14
heures 30
vous dites vous lisez votre roman c'est
marrant comme un roman vous avez c'est
une activité naturellement mental très
silencieuse l'écriture mais un roman
s'écrit aussi dans la bouche et le fait
d'être musicien c'est à dire confronté
éternellement très faim toute la journée
s'ils voulaient à des partitions quand
la partition n'est pas joué elle est
comme inertes et un livre quand vous le
recevez vous avez mis tellement d'infini
dans le livre et ça se résume à un
centimètre et demi d'épaisseur que quand
vous recevez lit je suis mais c'est pas
vrai si je ne l'interprètent pas si je
ne le dit pas si je ne le veulent pas
comme dirait flaubert et ben c'est comme
une partition qui serait un jouet non
pas injouable met à jouer c'est la
raison pour laquelle oui je le dis je le
gueule je lis sur scène et je crois
d'ailleurs que ça me permet à moi de
remettre éternellement ses mots et de
peut-être ces mots un mot ts et de me
guérir des autres avec en plus la force
de la scène que j'adore moi aussi j'ai
vécu moi aussi j'ai vécu le premier
roman des lieux cesu les est paru chez
flammarion il l'interprète au théâtre de
la contrescarpe tous les samedis à 14h
30 les flammes qui pleurent sont en
colère les photographes hybride et de
relance et aux éditions jeanne acquis et
l'exposition dure jusqu'à vendredi
jusqu'à vendredi
c'est à la sorbonne galerie dans dans la
sorbonne guerre et père de marianne big
c chez fayard et david à un code joue
animal tous les mercredis à 19h au point
virgule
merci merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]